SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALL RIGHT, JILL. OUR
STILETTO. ASHLEY. ATKINS BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR. BRADFORD. W R O
COURTESY. DAILY. DODD, DURAZO.
HAGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE
POTATO. JONES LAIRD DEMAND
MCGUIRE MANY OF OUR MEN. NEWMAN.
WHEN. NILO GOLDBERG TODAVÍA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO, SARTO
SKINNER. SMALL QUAVERS STERN.
HAMBURG. WELL, HOW WIENER. WILK.
MEMBERS OF QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE SENATE
RURAL 55 WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW GUESTS ON THE FLOOR. WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTERS, MICHELE GORMAN
, AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE OF FLOCK.
GRACIOUS GOD. AND THESE DAYS OF
CRAZINESS, WE NEED TO LEARN HOW
TO LOVE. THE POET ROSEMARY
TREMOR PRAISE IF SORROW IS HOW
WE LEARN TO LOVE THEN LET US
LEARN. ALREADY ENOUGH SORROWS
BEEN SOWN FOR WHOLE CONTINENTS
TO ERUPT INTO ASTONISHING
TENDERNESS. LET US LEARN. LET
COMPASSION GROW RAMPANT LIKE
SUNFLOWERS ALONG THE HIGHWAY.
EACH ACT OF KINDNESS REPLANT
ITSELF. INTO ACRES AND ACRES OF
WIDESPREAD DEVOTION. LET US
CHOOSE LOVE AS IF OUR LIVES
DEPEND ON IT. THE SORROW IS
GREAT. LET US LEARN TO LOVE
TOGETHER. RIOTOUS LOVE,
EXPANSIVE LOVE. LOVE SO ROOTED
SO COMMON. WE ALMOST FORGET THE
WORLD COULD LOOK ANY OTHER WAY.
AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
FLOAT. PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON MEMBERS
PRIVILEGED TO THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WOULD
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS AND
COMMITTEES WOULD BE TEAM RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR JANUARY
3 2024 THROUGH JANUARY, 31 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. MOVING ON NOW
TO INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ. CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO SENATE
THIRD READING FILES FILE ITEM
FOUR. S C, A ONE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN NEWMAN. ARE YOU PREPARED?
SENATOR FLOOR IS YOURS. CLERK.
PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT ONE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN AND ACTUALLY INTO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT TO ONE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT STATEWIDE. AND LEGISLATIVE
RECALLS IN CALIFORNIA ARE FAIR
AND EFFECTIVE BY ADJUSTING THE
CONDUCT OF STATE LEVEL RECALL
ELECTION SO THAT THE ONLY
QUESTION ON THE BALLOT IS THE
ONE THAT TRULY MATTERS. SHOULD
THE OFFICIAL BE RECALLED. YES OR
NO? CALIFORNIANS CAN BE
JUSTIFIABLY PROUD OF OUR HISTORY
OF AND COMMITMENT TO DIRECT
DEMOCRACY, WHICH HAS YIELDED
GROUNDBREAKING PROTECTIONS IN
REFORMS THAT DULY REFLECT THE
WILL OF CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS, THE
CURRENT TO QUESTION FORMAT FOR
STATE LEVEL RECALL ELECTIONS,
HOWEVER. IS A VESTIGE OF A VERY
DIFFERENT ERA WHERE WE'RE
CALLING A MALFEASANCE ELECTED
OFFICIAL WAS THE PRESUMED BEST
PATH TOWARDS BETTER OR MORE
HONEST GOVERNANCE IN AN ERA
WHERE MONEYED INTERESTS WERE
ASCENDANT AT THE STATE LEVEL
TODAY, HOWEVER, THE INCLUSION OF
THAT SECOND QUESTION AS TO WHO
SHOULD REPLACE THE TARGET OF A
STATE LEVEL RECALL SERVES A VERY
DIFFERENT AND UNINTENDED
FUNCTION. PRESENTING A POWERFUL
INCENTIVE TO INSTIGATE A RECALL
FOR STRICTLY POLITICAL REASONS,
SO AS TO ACHIEVE THROUGH A
SPECIAL ELECTION. WHAT WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT BE POSSIBLE IN A
NORMAL ELECTION WHERE AND WHERE
A REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE, ANY
FRACTURED FIELD CAN ASSUME THE
VACATED OFFICE WITH HIS LITTLE
AS 15% OF THE VOTE? IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE, MOREOVER,
THAT A RECALL VOTE IS ACTUALLY
NOT AN ELECTION PER SE. BUT IT
IS RATHER A REFERENDUM ON
WHETHER AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
RETAINS THE FULL FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE OF HIS OR HER VOTERS
IN PLACE OF THE SNAP ELECTION
ROLE OF THE SECOND QUESTION, A
RECALL STATE LEVEL OFFICIAL
WOULD BE REPLACED IN THE SAME
MANNER AS IF HE OR SHE LEFT
OFFICE FOR SOME OTHER REASON BY
IMPLEMENTING SAFEGUARDS THAT
SHIELD THE PROCESS FROM ABUSE
AND POLITICAL GAMESMANSHIP. YES
SHE A ONE WHEN PLACED ON THE
BALLOT AND APPROVED BY A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS
WILL REMOVE INCENTIVES FOR
GAMING THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM,
THEREBY RESTORING STATE LEVEL
ELECTIONS TO THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE AS A JUST AND MEASURED
CHECK ON CORRUPT OR MALFEASANCE.
STATE LEVEL PUBLIC OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR. SEE ARTO THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
OPPOSITION. TWO S C A ONE
BECAUSE VERY SIMPLY, IT'S NOT
NEEDED. IN THE LAST 113 YEARS
SINCE 1913 BASICALLY 100 11
YEARS. ONLY 11 OF 179. RECALL
ATTEMPTS HAVE COLLECTED ENOUGH
SIGNATURES EVEN QUALIFY FOR A
BALLOT. THAT'S LIKE 6% THAT
DOESN'T EXACTLY SCREAM OUT THAT
WE NEED REFORM. ON OUR RECALL
PROCESS. AND THE LATEST AND THE
LAST RECALL PROCESS. THE ONLY
REASON THE THAT PASSED WAS
BECAUSE WE HAD COVID. AND THEY
EXTENDED THE TIME FRAME FOR TO
COLLECT BALLOTS AND BECAUSE THEY
EXTENDED THAT TIME FRAME GUESS
WHAT IT PASSED. SO IF YOU WERE
LOOKING FOR A REFORM, PERHAPS
THAT SHOULD BE ONE EXTEND THE
TIME FRAME SO DEMOCRACY CAN BE
ENABLED. AND ALLOW MORE PEOPLE
TO INVOLVE THEMSELVES IN THE
COLLECTION PROCESS AND GETTING
THEIR SIGNATURES IN. THE
EXISTING FILING SIGNATURE AND
DEADLINE REQUIREMENTS. UH
THEY'RE EXPLICITLY BUILT TO
PREVENT EXPLOITATION. OF THE
SYSTEM. AND THE PEOPLE WHO WROTE
IT. HMM THEY HAD THAT IN MIND
WHEN THEY WROTE IT, AND THAT'S
WHY WE ONLY HAVE A 6% SUCCESS
RATE AND GETTING THESE TYPE OF
RECALLS ON A BALLOT. AS IT
RELATES TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. WHEN THE
POPULIST BECOMES SO UPSET THAT
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO RECALL A GOVERNOR. THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY ACCEPT UPSET AT
THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF OR OR HIS
PARTICULAR TRAIT OR OR PART OF
WHAT THEY MIGHT BE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WHAT THEY'RE UPSET AT. IS
THE DIRECTION THAT THEIR STATE
IS GOING. AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
SINGLE PARTY STATE. THAT OR ARE
MAJORITY STATE LIKE WE HAVE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO DO AND WHAT
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WANTS TO
DO. AS LIKE TWO PEOPLE GOING IN
THE SAME BOAT IN THE SAME
DIRECTION. PEOPLE WANT TO CHANGE
THE DIRECTION. IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN BY HAVING THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AUTOMATICALLY REPLACED
THE GOVERNOR. IN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM. WE CAN DO THAT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR CAN RUN. FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S SEAT. YES IT'S A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE TO RUN FOR
THE GUY YOU WANT TO SUPPORT YOU
LATER. UH, FOR THAT SEAT, BUT
THEY CAN DO THAT. AND THE AND
THE VOTERS CAN IMMEDIATELY FILL
THAT IN AND THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WOULD BECOME THE
GOVERNOR. SO IT'S NOT LIKE IT
CAN'T BE DONE. IT ALREADY CAN BE
DONE. AND AS FAR AS HAVING TOO
MANY PEOPLE COLLECT ON THE
BALLOT, AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
RECEIVED ALL OF YOUR BALLOT. UH
YOUR VALID INFORMATION THE
PAMPHLETS THIS YEAR TAKE A LOOK
AT R U S SENATE RACE. I DON'T.
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S 50 PEOPLE
ON THERE, SO THAT'S NOT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FIX. UM. AND ALSO, THIS ISN'T
JUST FOR THE GOVERNOR,
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THERE ARE
OTHER SEATS THAT COULD BE
RECALLED. LIKE PERHAPS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S. IF SOMEBODY
RECALLS THEIR DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO SIT AND
WAIT. FOR ANOTHER ELECTION TO BE
HELD TO REPLACE THEM. WHAT
TRANSPIRES. IN THAT VACUUM.
THAT'S WHY RECALLS WERE DONE THE
WAY THEY WERE. THEY REPLACED THE
PERSON IMMEDIATELY FOR THE SAKE
OF EXPERIENCIA AND MAKING THE
RECALL PROCESS WORK QUICKLY. A
QUICK RESOLUTION. THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS BUILT FOR. THIS NEW ATTEMPT
IS NOT A QUICK RESOLUTION. THIS
WILL CREATE BALLOT FATIGUE IF
YOU WILL, FOR SOME COMMUNITIES.
UM AND IT'S JUST NOT NECESSARY
FOR US. TO CONTINUE WITH OUR
DEMOCRACY. SO. I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR US TO MOVE ON WITH THE MORE
PRESSING ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO ATTACK
PROBLEMS LIKE THIS. THAT AREN'T
REALLY PROBLEMS. AND THE OTHER.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION
IS THIS IT SEEMS WHEN WE HAVE AN
S C A THAT POLLS AT 80% THAT WE
DON'T LIKE WE MAKE THOSE PEOPLE
PEOPLE, WE MAKE THE PUBLIC GO
OUT AND WORK HARD AND SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY GATHERING
SIGNATURES. BUT THEN WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T PULL WELL
, BUT WE'RE GOING TO TRY AND GET
IT ON THE BALLOT SO WE CAN
PROBABLY TALKED PEOPLE INTO
DOING IT. WE DO THIS PROCESS
WHERE WE SKIP THAT OTHER
PROCESS. THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO
IT. WE'LL DO IT FOR THEM. WE HAD
THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR WITH
THAT, SEE A FOR THE SAME THING
HAPPENED. THAT THAT PULLED THE
80. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS
PULLING OUT. BUT IF IT DOES, IT
PULLS IN REGIONS IT DOESN'T PULL
FOR THE STATE. SO WE DON'T NEED
THIS MEASURE. I WOULD I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER NOT DOING
THIS. IT WILL JUST BE ONE MORE
PROPOSITION ON THE BALLOT. HELP
CONFUSE PEOPLE. THERE WILL BE
MANY IN NOVEMBER. AND THIS WILL
JUST CONFUSE PEOPLE. WITH AN
OVERLOAD OF PROPOSITIONS. AND
THEN I KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT THIS WANTED TO SNEAK
THROUGH. AND THEN WE'LL HAVE ONE
MORE THING. THAT WILL CEMENT IN
THE CURRENT SYSTEM ARE A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM. AND CREATE
MORE DISTRUST IN THE SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE SO I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
ON SC A ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BLACK SPEAR. THANK
YOU. I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
C A ONE TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON FOR INTRODUCING THIS.
I THINK, UM, THIS IS I'M A PROUD
CO AUTHOR. AND I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL, WHICH
ANYBODY WHO WAS PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE LAST RECALL, I
THINK WOULD HAVE SIMILAR
INSIGHTS ABOUT THE REALITY THAT
THAT THE RECALL IS SUPPOSED TO
BE, AS THE AUTHOR SAID THE
RECALL IS A REFERENDUM ON THE
PERSON IN THE SEAT IS NOT AN
ELECTION. AND SO THE QUESTION OF
IS THIS PERSON DOING A GOOD JOB?
DO WE WANT TO REMOVE THEM? UM
THAT THE IF THEY ARE REMOVED, OR
IF THEY DIE IF THEY RESIGN IF
THEY'RE NOT IN THAT SEAT ANYMORE
, THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OR THE
SECOND PERSON UNDERNEATH WOULD
TAKE OVER THAT ROLE. AND TO ME,
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD
ASSIST AND WE SHOULD HAVE AND
WAS THE INSIGHT THAT I HAD, AND
MANY PEOPLE HAD PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE LAST RECALL. UM AND SO I
REALLY AM GRATEFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR BROUGHT THIS AND THAT WE
ARE HERE ABLE TO INTRODUCE IT
TODAY. UM AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR CLOSURE.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
I ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
A ONE I'LL ACKNOWLEDGE THE POINT
THAT MADE EARLIER BY THE SENATOR
FROM MARIETTA THAT IT IS A RARE
OCCURRENCE. THANK GOODNESS IN
OUR STATE. BUT IRRESPECTIVE OF
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WHEN IT
DOES HAPPEN, WE WANT IT TO
HAPPEN, RIGHT? FOR MEMBERS THAT
ARE NEW HERE IN THE BUILDING. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS, ALONG
WITH THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS, HELD JOINT HEARINGS
ON THIS ISSUE. UH A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO TO HEAR FROM EXPERTS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARS,
PROFESSORS AND THE REST TO
EXAMINE OUR RECALL PROCESS AND
WHAT WOULD MAKE IT BETTER. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION ALSO DID A
STUDY TO LOOK AT THIS. AT THIS
DYSFUNCTION THAT WE SAW IN THE
LAST RECALL ELECTION. AND I
THINK WHAT THIS MEASURE SPEAKS
TO. MOST IMPORTANTLY, IS THAT A
MAJORITY VOTE FOR THE GOVERNOR
OF THIS STATE MATTERS. SIMPLE AS
THAT. WE DON'T WANT ACCIDENTS TO
HAPPEN THAT WE WANT TO
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS AND WHERE A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS SAY
THAT'S THE PERSON GREAT. THAT'S
THE PERSON AND I THINK THAT'S
FUNDAMENTAL TO WHAT THIS MEASURE
PROPOSES TO DO. AND FINALLY, UM
THIS MEASURE IS SIMPLY PLACES IT
ON THE BALLOT FOR THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE. THIS ISN'T AN ACTION OF
THE SENATE THAT PUTS IT INTO LAW
IMMEDIATELY. IT PUTS THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE VOTERS WHICH
WHO CAN HAVE AN OBJECTION TO
THAT. LET THEM MAKE THE CHOICE
AS TO HOW THEY WANT THEIR RECALL
PROCESS TO BE CHANGED OR NOT. I
THINK IT'S A SMART REFORM.
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FROM
FULLERTON FOR AUTHORING IT. AND
I HOPE WE'LL SUPPORT TODAY S D A
ONE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? MENDOCINE ON SENATOR
NEWMAN. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES, UM LET ME TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF POINTS TO THE TO THE
ASSERTION THAT THIS IS NOT
NEEDED. AND THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT HAPPEN OFTEN. JUST BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN OFTEN DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S NOT NEEDED. I THINK
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE LAST
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL POINT TO
THE FACT THAT IT IS NEEDED AND
THAT RECALL NOT ONLY TOOK POLICE
EVERY TIME WHERE THERE WERE MUCH
MORE PRESSING NEEDS THAT YOU
KNOW $100 MILLION OR SO WAS
SPENT. TO NO GOOD EFFECT AT ALL.
THE RESULTS WERE NO DIFFERENT
THAN HIS ORIGINAL ELECTION. TO
THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ASCENDING
INTO THE ROLE. I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THOSE TWO OFFICES ARE
ELECTED INDEPENDENTLY. THERE IS
NO CERTAINTY THAT IN THE FUTURE
THAT THEY WON'T BELONG TO
DIFFERENT PARTIES. UM TO THE
QUESTIONS OR POINTS RAISED ABOUT
THE THRESHOLD. THAT'S SOMETHING
TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO CHAIRS THE
ELECTION. COMMITTEE WE LOOKED AT
THIS AS PART OF THE JOINT
HEARINGS, AND THE DECISION WAS
MADE NOT TO ADDRESS THAT THAT
THE THRESHOLD WAS STILL
APPROPRIATE. BUT TO THE BROADER
QUESTION OF THE ROLE AND
INCENTIVES CREATED BY THE SECOND
QUESTION, THERE IS A CONSENSUS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT A
BUNCH OF VERY SMART, VERY
ENGAGED. PEOPLE. LOOK AT THIS.
UM AND THE AND THE CONSENSUS IS
NOT ONLY THAT IT'S NECESSARY ON
THEIR PART, BUT IT IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY PULLING THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN IS SMARTER THAN WE
OFTEN GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR, AND
THEY AGREE, ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT
OF THE LAST RECALL EFFORT THAT
THIS PROCESS IS IN DO NEED OF
REFORM. UM AND SO THIS DOES NOT
IN ANY WAY REDUCE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT DIRECT
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. WHAT IT WHAT
IT ASPIRES TO DO IS RETURN IT TO
ITS ORIGINAL INTENDED PURPOSE AS
A TEST AND VALIDATION OF THE
INTEGRITY OR THE MALFEASANCE.
THAT WOULD BE TARGETED, ELECTION
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND THEN FROM
THERE WITH THE PUBLIC, HAVING
HAD THEIR SAY, WE WILL DULY
REPLACE THAT PUBLIC SERVANT WITH
ANOTHER, USING THE NORMAL
PROCESS, AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T I
BROUGHT IN YOUNG HI OUR GELATO.
AYE, ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR. BRADFORD. CAVIAR
ĐÓ. I SEE. DOLLY! NÓ DODD. I
WAS. OH, I ADMIN. GLASER. BY
GONZALEZ. GROVE. NO. JONES. NÓ
LAIRD. AYE. AYE, MCGUIRE. AYE,
MENJIVAR. I MEAN, AYE, NEWMAN. I
WIN. NO. HELLO. NO A JOB, OKAY?
NO, BUT DO PORTANTINO RATH.
RUBIO. CIERTO. NÓ SKINNER. I
SMOKE WAIVERS. AYE, STERN. I
HAMBURG. I HAB AYE, WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SALAS.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. ONE MORE TIME.
ONE MORE TIME. CALL THE ABSOLUTE
NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME, PLEASE.
WHO'S ALWAYS PORTANTINO RUBIO.
BYE. 30 NOTICE SEVEN. THE
MEASURE PASSES AH! I STAND
CORRECTED EYES. 31 KNOWS SEVEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR GROVER YOU
PREPARED SHE IS SENATOR GIRL,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
MR PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF TAMIKA FOSS, THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATIONS. THIS IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL NOMINEE. SHE STOOD
BEFORE US AND ARE SET BEFORE US,
AND SHE ANSWERED EVERY QUESTION
WITH NO NOTES AND HAD A WEALTH
OF KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE INNER
WORKINGS OF THIS CDCR SYSTEM,
AND, UM FROM BOTH SIDES. SHE IS
SHE STARTED AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER BACK, I BELIEVE IN 1996.
AND THEN WORKED HER WAY UP AND
BECAME A WARDEN AND THEN STARTED
IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE PIECE OF
IT OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND THEN
NOW THE APPOINTMENT IS THE
UNDERSECRETARY FOR THE CDCR. I
CAN TELL YOU OR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATIONS. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT, LIKE I SAID SHE SAID
BEFORE US SHE HAD NO NOTES. SHE
ANSWERED EVERY QUESTION, AND SHE
NOT ONLY HAD ANSWERED EVERY
QUESTION SHE HAD SOLUTIONS FOR
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE FACING
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM, AND I
THINK THE ENTIRE RULES BOARD
WITH HER UNANIMOUS CONFIRMATION,
HAS FULL CONFIDENCE IN HER AND
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE SENATOR DAHLE, RICK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT. THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD SAID MOST OF WHAT I
WAS GOING TO SAY, BUT I JUST ON
THE RULES COMMITTEE, SENATOR
GROVE AND I WAS JUST SO
FREQUENTLY AGREE. THIS WAS ONE
OF THOSE PLACES. THIS WAS ONE OF
THOSE PLACES BECAUSE SHE WAS A
STARTING CORRECTIONS OFFICER IN
ONE OF THE TOUGHEST PRISONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SHE
WORKED HER WAY UP COMPLETELY IN
A WAY THAT IS WHAT'S SAID SHE
WAS SO ARTICULATE AND SO ON TOP
OF THE ISSUES THAT FOR THIS
POSITION TREES GOOD AND WHEN I
VISITED A PRISON IN MY DISTRICT
THIS LAST FRIDAY THEY HAD ALL
BEEN WATCHING THE RULES
COMMITTEE HEARING, SO I HOPE
THEY'RE WATCHING NOW TO KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT A PERFUNCTORY
CONFIRMATION THAT WE RECOGNIZED
THE GOODNESS IN THIS CANDIDATE
AND I'LL BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
HER CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I'M SORRY, SENATOR GROW.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS AND, UM, IT
IS NOT AND TO JUST TO REITERATE
ONE MORE TIME SHE HAS LIVED
EXPERIENCE FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE CDCR PROCESS TO HOPEFULLY A
FUTURE POSITION IN A HIGHER
ROLE. BUT RIGHT NOW WE'LL TAKE
HER AS THE UNDER SECRETARY OF
OPERATIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE APPOINTMENT. ALAN I WROTE
A GILL. AYE, ARCHULETTA. BY
ASHBY. BY ATKINS. AYE, BECKER.
AYE, BLACKSBURG. BY BRADFORD. I
W R O AYE, CORTESI. I REALLY
DODD. HI. THERE WAS ĐÓ. BY
ADMIN. GLASER. I. GONZALES.
GROVE. I DON'T KNOW. JONES. I
LAYERED AYE, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE. I
MEAN, BREVARD, I MEANT AYE,
NEWMAN. I WHEN I KNEEL ĐÓ. I
BROKE I AM. AYE, PORTANTINO.
RAT. AYE, RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO.
AYE, SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
QUIVERS. AYE STERN. I HAMBURG.
HOB. AYE, WIENER. I WILL. I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HAGMAN I GONZALEZ. OR 0.0. I
LIMÓN. AYE. PORTANTINO. I XYZ 38
NO. ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. VIOLATE HIM,
TOO, IS A CONFIRMATION OF DAVID
LEWIS IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MADE AN
INSTRUMENT AT CDCR. BEFORE HE
WAS IN THIS ROLE. HE SERVED AS A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES, SUPPORT AND THE
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE STAFF
SERVICES. AND HE'S ALSO A FORMER
STATE SENATE STAFF, HAVING
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A
CONSULTANT IN THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN FISCAL OFFICE. HE,
TOO, HAS A WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
ON THE VACATED FACILITIES THAT
WE ARE LEAVING ABANDONED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. UM I LOVE HIS OUT OF
THE BOX THINKING WHEN HE WAS
LOOKING AT HOPEFULLY BEING ABLE
TO REPURPOSE SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES THAT MIGHT BE IF THEY
WERE AVAILABLE, UH MORE TO THE
PUBLIC AND NOT IN SUCH FAR AWAY
AREAS FROM POPULATION, BUT HE
REALLY IS THINKING OUTSIDE THE
BOX TO WHAT TO DO WITH THESE
FACILITIES AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOUSING THE
INCARCERATED THAT THEY HAVE A
SAFE FACILITY TO BE INCARCERATED
IN. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. MENDOCINE, UN SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
WROTE TO YOU. HI, ARCH ILETO.
AYE, ASHBY. HI ATKINS. BECKER. I
BLAKE SPEAR, BRADFORD. CAVIAR
ĐÓ. AYE, CORTESI. I DOLLY. BY
GOD. I DURAZO. I ADMIN. AYE,
GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE, I
THOUGHT OH, AYE, JONES. AYE,
LAIRD. AYE, MOMENT. I REQUIRE. I
MADE A BAR I MEN AYE, NEWMAN. I
WENT I KNEEL ĐÓ. AYE. I DO.
PORTANTINO ROD. AYE, RUBIO. AYE,
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALL
GRIEVERS STERN. I AM BERG. I HAB
AYE WINNER. WILK. HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
AYE. GONZALEZ. PORTANTINO
WIENER. AYE. 38 NO. ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
FOLLOW THEM. THREE SENATOR
GROWTH, I THINK. OH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM THREE IS
BOTH FOR KIMBERLY CRAIG AND
WILLIE PELOTON. AN APPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION IN
STATE FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
MRS CRAIG IS CURRENTLY A PARTNER
WITH THE LOBBY INFORMATION RC
STRATEGIES MOST PREVIOUSLY
PREVIOUSLY SHE SERVED AS A CHIEF
DEPUTY CABINET SECRETARY IN THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNOR BROWN. HER
CAREER IN THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDES SERVING AS CHIEF OF
STAFF OF THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
ATKINS. SENATE PRO TEM NOW, UM
AND LATER, A SPECIAL ASSISTANT
TO DEPUTY ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
ATKINS. UH MR PELOTAS CURRENTLY
RENTS FOR POLLUTES. EXCUSE ME,
CURRENTLY RUNS POLLUTE STRATEGY,
CONSULTING AN ADVOCACY AND HE
HAS A LONG CAREER IN BOTH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF STAFF AND
ADVOCATE ADVOCACY, INCLUDING AS
A POLICY CONSULTANT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN.
BOTH APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
24TH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I JUST WANTED TO PUT IN
A GOOD WORD REAL QUICK FOR MR
PELOTON WHEN I FIRST GOT ELECTED
IN 2010. HE WAS ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST SACRAMENTO PROFESSIONALS
TO COME INTO MY OFFICE AND
INTRODUCE HIMSELF. UH KNOWING
THAT THERE WOULD PROBABLY BE
SOME DISAGREEMENT ON THE ISSUES
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO HIM AND
THE ISSUES THAT WERE IMPORTANT
TO ME, BUT I REALLY APPRECIATED
THAT MEETING AND HIS, UH,
HONESTY AND KNOWING THAT HE IS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR THE THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO HIM HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
KNOW HE'LL BE A FIERCE ADVOCATE.
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND I
SUPPORT HIS, UH, CONFIRMATION
TODAY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
YOU WERE GONNA ASK SOME MEMBERS
TO TAKE THEIR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR HAS BEEN A LITTLE
NOISY, INTEGRAL. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ON THIS APPOINTMENT?
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
BROUGHT A GIRL. HI ARCHER
LETTER. I ASKED BE. BY ATKINS.
AYE, BECKER. I BLAKE SPEAR. AYE,
BRADFORD. CAVIAR ĐÓ. AYE, CORTEZ
E. I DOLLY. DODD. I TERRAZZO.
AYE, EGGMAN. AYE, GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. GROWTH. I THOUGHT, OH,
BY JONES. AYE, LAIRD. AYE,
LIMÓN. AYE, MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENJIVAR. I MEAN, AYE, NEWMAN. I
WIN. I KNEEL ĐÓ. I KNOW BOOK. I
DO. AYE, PORTANTINO. RATH. AYE,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO TOÀN SKINNER
. SMALL CRATERS. I STERN I AM
BERG. I WOULD HAVE. HI WIENER.
AYE, WILK. AYE. 38 NO. ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MEMBERS REMOVING THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE ITEM 15.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE PREPARED.
OKAY, BR. I'M SORRY. COPY HERO
AND THERE SHE IS, OKAY. OKAY?
MORNING FOR IT. SECRETARY POLICE
ROUTE. SENATE RESOLUTION 58 BUS,
SENATOR KAY VIETTO, RELATIVELY
COW ETEC AWARENESS WEEK. SENIOR
CAVIAR ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT OUR 58, WHICH
ESTABLISHES JANUARY 26TH THROUGH
FEBRUARY 2ND AS A CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
AWARENESS WEEK OR EAT CALLIE
EITC. ESTABLISHED IN 2015 IN
RESPONSE TO AN INCREASE IN THE
POVERTY RATE IN THE STATE. THE
CALI I T C PROGRAM PROVIDES LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WITH A RANGE OF TAX CREDITS AND
IN COMBINATION WITH OTHER SAFETY
. NET TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS
SERVICES STRONG TOOL TO REDUCE
POVERTY MODELED AFTER THE
FEDERAL EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. THE COUNTY EITC PROGRAM
PROVIDES FINANCIAL RELIEF TO LOW
INCOME WORKING INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILY. CALIFORNIA'S
VERSION GOES EVEN FURTHER.
BECAUSE IT'S TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF THE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION, KELLY I T C HAS BEEN
MODIFIED TO INCREASE ELIGIBILITY
. THIS INCLUDES INCREASING THE
MAXIMUM INCOME, LOWERING THE AGE
REQUIREMENT AND EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY TO FILERS WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER OR I 10, DEPENDING ON
HOUSEHOLD SIZE, ELIGIBLE TAX
FILERS CAN RECEIVE A CREDIT
PAYMENT OF JUST OVER $3500,
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA MORE
THAN 3.6 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
CLAIM THE CREDIT IN 2021
FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY FOR KELLY
IT WITH YOUNG CHILDREN ALSO
QUALIFY FOR THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT. THESE CREDITS NOW PUT
OVER $1.3 BILLION INTO THE HANDS
OF ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS AND IS A
LIFE CHANGING PROGRAM. THAT'S
THAT'S THAT SUPPORTS THOSE MOST
IN NEED. DESPITE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS, MANY ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE MISSING OUT ON
TAX CREDITS. THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SET ASIDE
FOR THE PROGRAM ARE CURRENTLY
UNCLAIMED. BECAUSE VERY LOW WAGE
EARNERS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO FILE
TAXES, OR THEY ARE UNAWARE THAT
THE CREDITS AVAILABLE SO THE
RESOLUTION FOLKS CALLS ATTENTION
TO THE BENEFITS OF KELLY E I. T
C IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMS BUT ALSO TO
SHOW APPRECIATION FOR THE ON THE
GROUND SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH
THE VOLUNTEER INCOME TAX
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM, PUSH IT OUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A PROGRAM FOR WHICH THEY
MAY BE ELIGIBLE. UM AND THAT CAN
HAVE A TREMENDOUSLY POSITIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE HERE INSANE? NONE
SECRETARY POLICE CALLED THE ROW
ALLEN. I WROTE AGAIN. ARCHER
LETO. AYE, ASHBY. AYE, ATKINS.
BECKER. BY SHAKESPEARE. AYE,
BRADFORD. CAVIAR ĐÓ. ORTEZ. I
DOLLY. DODD. I DURAZO. HI,
ADMIN. GLASER. I WAS ALWAYS
GROWTH. HER 0.0. AYE, JONES.
LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. I REQUIRE BY
THE BAR. I MEAN, HI, NEWMAN. I
WIN. HELLO. A CHILD VOTE. I DO.
AYE, PORTANTINO. RATH. AYE,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALL WAIVERS. AYE, STERN.
HI, HAMBURG. AYE. HOB. AYE,
WIENER. I WELCOME AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BACKINGS? AYE. DAILY. HI. SALAS.
GROVE. AYE. JONES. WHEN HELLO.
PORTANTINO CR TOÀN. 34 NOS.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW
IT'S YOUR TIME FOR ADJOURNED
MEMORIES. SENATOR WAHA. WHAT?
SOONER OR WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. THANK THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANTED TO, UM, MOVE THE
FALLEN ITEMS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. FILE ITEM. 10 SCR 100 BY
ITEM 11 SCR 101 BY ITEM 12 SCR
1035 ITEMS 13 SCR 104 THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE DEATHS WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO A
JOURNEY MEMORIES FIRST UP. WE
HAVE SENATOR WAHAB WHILE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF FIVE TIME FREMONT
MAYOR GUS MORRISON, WHO PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER 14TH AT THE AGE
OF 88 AS A LEADER, HE
PRIORITIZED THE COMMUNITY WITH
SERVICES AND PROJECTS LIKE
SUPPORTING HIGH DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT TO HELP LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. THE AWARD WINNING
SUNRISE VILLAGE HOMELESS
SHELTER, THE FIRST SHELTER IN
THE NATION BUILT TO ACCOMMODATE
FAMILIES ESTABLISHING ART AND
WOULD HISTORIC FARM PARK,
INTRODUCING CURBSIDE RECYCLING
AND LOCAL HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE DROP OFF AND MANY OTHER
SERVICES AND PROJECTS RELATED TO
THIS DEEP PASSION FOR SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. GUS
UNDERSTOOD AND APPRECIATED THE
VALUE OF THE BLOOMING DIVERSITY
OF THE CITY. HE LED, ONCE
COMMENTING ON THE NEED TO KEEP
AN OPEN MIND AND CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY. MORRISON THE ELDEST
SON OF SCOTTISH IMMIGRANTS, GREW
UP IN NEW YORK NEAR THE CANADIAN
BORDER. HE SERVED IN THE NAVY
DURING THE KOREAN WAR AND
ATTRIBUTED WHO HE HAD BECOME TO
HIS YEARS OF SERVICE AND
APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE HIS COUNTRY. HE SPENT 53
YEARS OF HIS LIFE MARRIED TO HIS
WIFE, JOY UNTIL HER DEATH IN
2012 AND IS SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN. I
WILL ALSO SAY THAT GUS WAS A
LEADER IN PARTICULAR THAT WOULD
REACH OUT TO OTHER UPCOMING
LEADERS AND SPEND TIME WITH
THEM. TALK TO THEM, MENTOR THEM
AND DO MUCH MORE THAN JUST BEING
A LEADER HIMSELF. HE WAS A
FRIEND. HE WAS A MENTOR. HE WAS
A COLLEAGUE, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, HE WAS A GOOD HUMAN
BEING. ANGUS GUS HUGH MORRISON
SERVED THE PUBLIC FOR MORE THAN
25 YEARS, MAKING FREMONT AND THE
EAST BAY ALL THE BETTER FOR IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
SENT YOU BRING HIS NAME FOR IT
SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. OKAY SKINNER.
I'M SORRY, SENATOR SKINNER ON
THE SAME AH, THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS. I ALSO WANTED TO STAND
IN OUR JOURNEY IN MEMORY FOR GUS
MORRISON. HE AND I SERVED US
STARTED HIS SERVICE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN IN THE EARLY
EIGHTIES, BACK WHEN I WAS ON THE
BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL, UM HE
THEN TOOK A PAUSE FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR SOME TIME AND
CAME BACK AND BECAME MAYOR OF
FREMONT. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE BOTH SHARED WAS A PASSION FOR
LIVE MUSIC, AND HE ATTENDED MANY
CONCERTS AND SHOWS AT VARIOUS,
UH, MUSIC VENUES WITHIN MY
COMMUNITY AND OAKLAND AND
FREMONT, WHICH WE, UH YOU KNOW,
SHARE TOGETHER AND HE WAS HE HAD
A JOY FOR LIFE, BUT HE WAS ALSO
A VERY DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
AND I ASK ALSO FOR THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU. NOW SENATOR SMALLWOOD
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. TODAY I AM PROUD TO
RISE AND HONOR OF A REMARKABLE
WOMAN. A WOMAN WHO ALWAYS GAVE
ME A KIND WORD, PARTICULARLY AS
WE WERE ORGANIZING IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT TOGETHER. THE BEAUTIFUL
BOBBY JEAN ANDERSON. BOBBY JEAN
WAS A FORMIDABLE FIGURE IN LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY AND POLITICS
AND A DEAR FRIEND OF SO MANY
YOUNG ORGANIZER'S WOMEN
ORGANIZER'S PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO WORKED IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES, BRINGING LOW WAGE
WORKERS INTO UNIONS. AND THEN
WORKING WITH THEM AS UNION
LEADERS TO HELP THEM FIGHT FOR
BETTER CONTRACTS, BENEFITS AND
HIGHER WAGES. MISS ANDERSON HAS
LEFT A REMARKABLE LEGACY BECAUSE
HER LIFE FROM HER EARLY TEENAGE
YEARS TO UH IN WELL INTO HER
EIGHTIES SHE WAS A DEVOTED
HUMANITARIAN AND A FIERCE
WOMEN'S ADVOCATE. AS A
TRAILBLAZER FOR WORKERS. SHE
WORKED AS A LABOR LEADER FOR S C
I U 660 IF THOSE OF YOU DON'T
KNOW 660 REPRESENTS ALL OF THE
COUNTY WORKERS IN L. A AND IT
WASN'T ALWAYS THAT COUNTY
WORKERS HAD GOOD JOBS. UH BOBBY
JEAN ANDERSON AND A NUMBER OF
WOMEN, UH, WORKED TO BUILD A NEW
REPUTATION FOR WHAT IT MEANT TO
BE A PUBLIC SECTOR WORKER, NOT
JUST IN A UNION AND RECEIVING A
PAYCHECK, BUT SAYING THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE IN THIS UNION AND
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE TO FIGHT TO
ORGANIZE THIS UNION, WE HAVE TO
FIGHT TO MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE
TO RAISE THE STANDARDS FOR
WORKERS WHO DO. IN TREMENDOUS
AND PROVIDE TREMENDOUS SERVICE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY, AND 660 WAS
ONE OF THOSE UNIONS THAT NOT
ONLY FOUGHT FOR THEIR WAGES, BUT
THEY ALSO FOUGHT TO MAKE SURE
THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, URGENT CARE
CENTERS REMAINED OPEN IN THE
COUNTY. THEY MOVED INITIATIVES
THAT ENSURED THAT THAT WOMEN,
PARTICULARLY WOMEN, IN IN OUR
BIRTHING CENTERS, HAD FAIR
RATIOS IN COUNTY HOSPITALS THEY
FALL. TO MAKE SURE THAT
FACILITIES LIKE MARTIN LUTHER
KING HOSPITAL, VERY STAUNCH
ADVOCATES FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THAT HOSPITAL REMAINED OPEN IN
SOUTH L. A. AND BOBBY G.
ANDERSON WAS RIGHT THERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THOSE STRUGGLES
THROUGHOUT HER 40 YEAR CAREER.
SHE WORKED ALSO IN THE LOS
ANGELES PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
, SHE HELPED PREPARE YOUTH FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE CAREERS AND
ENSURED THERE WERE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS. TO HELP THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED TO BE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT COULD HELP THEM
GROW AND BLOOM AND BECOME STRONG
COMMUNITY LEADERS LIKE HER. SHE
ENSURED THAT SHE BROUGHT
TOGETHER THE COUNTY RESOURCES
AND PARTICULARLY THE RESOURCES
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
TO DO THAT, AND 2013 GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN APPOINTED MS
ANDERSON AS COMMISSIONER ON THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY POST, WHERE SHE MAY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING AGAIN
PATHWAYS. VOCATIONAL TRAINING
FOR YOUTH IN THE COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO GAIN A SKILL THAT COULD
SERVE THEM FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. MRS ANDERSON WAS ALSO
COMMITTED TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AS CHAIR OF THE BLACK
WOMEN'S FORUM CRIMINAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TASK FORCE. SHE WAS
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING PROGRAMS
TO HELP WOMEN SUCCESSFULLY RE
ENTER. COMMUNITIES SHE
UNDERSTOOD THAT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAD TO GET TO THE
ROOT CAUSE AND THAT CAUSE IS
OFTEN COMPOUNDED POVERTY AND
LACK OF ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY
SHE ADVOCATED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND TO ENSURE THAT MEN
AND WOMEN COULD SUCCESSFULLY RE
ENTER INTO OUR COMMUNITY AFTER
SERVING. THEIR THEIR THEIR TIME
IN 1995. BILL CLINTON RECOGNIZED
BOBBY JEAN ANDERSON'S CRUCIAL
WORK IN THIS SPACE AS SHE WAS
ONE OF THE VERY EARLY ADVOCATES
FOR RETURNING CITIZENS AND RE
ENTRY PROGRAMS, AND HE APPOINTED
HER TO THE NATIONAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TASK FORCE. MRS ANDERSON
WAS ALSO A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
PROGRESSIVE POLITICS. SERVING IN
OUR PARTY AND SERVING IT. WELL
UM, PROVIDING OVER A DECADE OF
SERVICE ON THE DEMOCRATIC STATE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND IN HER
ROLE IN THE LOS ANGELES
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION, SHE
WAS A FIERCE ADVOCATE OF FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR MAINTAINING
REPRESENTATION FOR SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND ENSURING POLITICAL
RESOURCE AND POWER IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THROUGHOUT HER CAREER
, MS. ANDERSON WAS THE RECIPIENT
OF MANY REWARDS AWARDS. SHE WAS
TWICE AWARDED THE L. A COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTIES. I'M SORRY,
THE L. A COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTIES DEMOCRAT OF THE YEAR.
SHE ALSO RECEIVED THE GENESIS
CENTER, WHICH IS A PHENOMENAL
CENTER THAT SERVES WOMEN WHO ARE
ADDRESSING AND SURVIVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SHE RECEIVED
THEIR SILVER ROSE AWARD FOR HER
WORK. AND A LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT
AWARD FROM S. C I U 7 TO 1 AND
AN IMAGE OF EXCELLENT AWARD FROM
THE MOON, LAMBDA LAMBDA OMEGA
CHAPTER OF A K A SORORITY, AND
THAT'S JUST TO NAME A FEW. THERE
WERE SO MANY AWARDS I DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH TIME AND SPACE ON IN
OUR SESSION TODAY, BUT IF YOU
WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT BOBBY
JEAN, JUST GOOGLE HER AND YOU
WILL FIND OUT SO MUCH ABOUT HER
WORK. AS WE REMEMBER BOBBY JEAN
ANDERSON, LET US LIFT UP HER
PASSIONATE LEADERSHIP AND
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL
JUSTICE. A LIFE OF REMINDERS OF
HOW IMPORTANT ONE INDIVIDUAL'S
LIFE CAN HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
IMPACT ACROSS COMMUNITIES. IT'S
BECAUSE OF HEARD PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF. WE'RE ABLE TO STEP INTO
THIS CHAMBER LEARNING WHAT
COMMUNITY SERVICE MEANT LEARNING
WHAT PERSISTENCE MEANT WEREN'T
LEARNING WHAT DETERMINATION
MEANT FOR WORKERS FOR WOMEN FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. MISS ANDERSON
LEAVES BEHIND A SON, ANDY. TWO
GRANDCHILDREN, ANTHONY DESERT
DESERT ANTHONY AND DESIREE AND
ONE GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER, JALEN.
UM. WE AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE OFFER OUR DIFFERENCES
CONCERN CONDOLENCES TO MS
ANDERSON'S FAMILY AND ALL OF
THOSE WHO WERE TOUCHED BY HER
EXTRAORDINARY LIFE AND ON A
PERSONAL NOTE, UM THIS IS THE
FIRST MENTOR THAT I GREW UP IN
THE MOVEMENT WITH, UM SO IT WAS
HARD TO HEAR OF HER PASSING. BUT
IT WAS A LIFE WELL LIVED IN. MAY
SHE REST IN POWER, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZO. I
WILL ONLY ADD TO WHAT THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES SAID IS
, UM BOBBY JEAN WAS HAPPY.
JOYFUL POSITIVE AND EXCITING
PERSON TO BE AROUND AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT I WAS ALONG HER
SIDE SIDE BY SIDE ON MANY, MANY
ISSUES AND CAMPAIGNS, SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HER NAME FORD SO SHE CAN
BE PROPERLY MORE ALLIES. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR ON BURKE. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I HAVE
THE SAD PRIVILEGE OF HONORING
THE LIFE. OF NAVY SEALS, SPECIAL
OPERATOR FIRST CLASS CHRIS
CHAMBERS. WHO DIED? WHO
SACRIFICED HIS LIFE FOR ALL OF
US AN EFFORT TO SAVE A FELLOW
SEAL. IN THE EARLY MORNING HOURS
OF JANUARY. 11TH SPECIAL
OPERATOR FIRST CLASS CHRIS
CHAMBERS OF NAVY SEAL TEAM THREE
ALONG WITH HIS FELLOW SEAL TEAM
OPERATORS CLIMBED ABOARD A SHIP
THAT WAS CARRYING ILLICIT
IRANIAN MADE WEAPONS TO YEMEN.
WITH CHRIS WAS NAVY SPECIAL
WARFARE OPERATOR SECOND CLASS
NATHAN GAUGE INGRAM IT WAS
DURING THIS OPERATION THAT
NATHAN SLIPPED AND FELL INTO THE
WATER BETWEEN THE VESSEL AND THE
SEALS COMBAT CRAFT. CHRIS
CHAMBERS. DOVE IN THE WATER TO
SAVE HIM. APPARENTLY THE NAVY
SEAL PROTOCOL IS IF ONE SEAL
GOES IN ANOTHER SEAL IMMEDIATELY
JUMPS IN TO SAVE THEM. CHRIS WAS
THAT SECOND SEAL WHO JUMPED IN
TO SAVE HIM. TRAGICALLY, BOTH
MEN LOST THEIR LIVES. CHRIS WAS
37 NATHAN 27. CHRIS CHAMBERS
GREW UP IN CHEVERLY, MARYLAND,
HE ATTENDED BISHOP MCNAMARA HIGH
SCHOOL IN PRINCE GEORGE'S COUNTY
FOR TWO YEARS BEFORE MOVING TO
MASSACHUSETTS TO ATTEND.
WESTFIELD HIGH SCHOOL. IN HIGH
SCHOOL. CHRIS EXCELLED AS AN
ATHLETE AND FELL IN LOVE WITH
SWIMMING. IN 2004. HE LED HIS
HIGH SCHOOL TEAM TO A STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP AND WON AN
INDIVIDUAL TITLE IN THE 50
FREESTYLE 2005. FORMER COACH
SAID HE REMEMBERED CHRIS ASKING
HIM ONE DAY. HOW DO I NOT ONLY
BECOME A BETTER SWERVE BUT USE
MY SWIMMING TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE? HE FOUND A WAY CHRIS
WOULD GO ON TO SWIM FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF MASSACHUSETTS IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND. HE
LISTENED TO THE NAVY IN 2012 AND
GRADUATED FROM SEAL TRAINING A
DECADE AGO IN 2014. HE SERVED
TWO DEPLOYMENTS ONE AND TWO IN
IRAQ AND HIS THIRD AND ASIANS
FINAL DEPLOYMENT, AS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE MIDDLE EAST. HE
SERVED AS A SEAL FOR OVER A
DECADE AND RECEIVED AWARDS,
INCLUDING THE NAVY MARINE CORPS
ACHIEVEMENT. METAL WITH A COMBAT
SEE DEVICE AND THREE NAVY MARINE
CORPS OTHER ACHIEVEMENT MEDALS.
CHRIS IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE,
MCHALE DAUGHTER KENNEDY, WHO'S
THREE YEARS OLD. MOTHER LOIS,
FATHER, KEVIN, SISTER, MELANIE.
UM AND HIS BEST FRIEND NATE
BOLLINGER. UM CANDIDATE PROBABLY
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
ON. BUT A SPECIAL MESSAGE AND
RECOGNITION TO HER FOR HER
SACRIFICE AND MCHALE SACRIFICE
THEIR BEARING THE DEBT THAT THAT
WE ALL OWE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
TO THEM FOR THEIR SACRIFICE. SO
SOMEDAY. IF KENNEDY SEES THIS
SHE WILL KNOW THAT HER FATHER
DEFINES THE TERM HERO. AND WE
WILL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL. TO HIM
AND TO THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR AMBERG, SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, I FIRST MET CHRIS. I
BELIEVE IT WAS IN THE SPRING OF
2012. I WAS RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE AT THAT TIME WAS A
CANDIDATE AND I HAD BEEN INVITED
AS A GUEST. TO THE PRO TIM CUP
IN IN SAN DIEGO. CHRIS AND HIS
FRIEND NATE. THE SON OF ONE OF
MY VERY, VERY GOOD FRIENDS. THEY
WERE THERE AS GUESTS TO THEY
WERE IN THE NAVY. THEY WERE
TRAINING IS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY INDICATED TO BE
NAVY SEALS AT BUDS AND SAN
DIEGO. IT WAS THEIR DAY OFF. AND
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WHO'VE HAD
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THE NAVY, AND MAYBE SOME
HAVE BEEN IN TRAINING TO BE IN
THE SPECIAL FORCES. THEY DON'T
GET MANY DAYS OFF IN BUDS
TRAINING. BUT THEY TWO OF THEM
DECIDED TO SPEND THEIR DAY OFF
WITH PEOPLE LIKE ME. I WAS
BEYOND IMPRESSED. THOSE TWO WERE
YOUNG. THEY WERE BRIGHT. THEY
WERE STRONG. THEY WERE
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THEIR FUTURE
AND THE REASON FOR IT AND THEY
UNDERSTOOD THE DANGER. FRANKLY
THAT FACE THEM IF THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL. AND IT SIMPLY DIDN'T
FAZE THEM. THEY WERE TRAINING.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, TO PROTECT
ALL OF THE REST OF US. FOR ME
THINKING BACK TO MY MILITARY
SERVICE AS I WAS STANDING THERE
TALKING TO THESE TWO YOUNG NAVY
SAILORS. I KNEW THAT I NEVER HAD
THE TALENT, THE ABILITY OF,
FRANKLY, THE COURAGE TO DO WHAT
THEY WERE ATTEMPTING TO DO. THAT
WAS THE LAST TIME I SAW CHRIS.
THE TWO OF THEM CHRIS AND NATE
HAD THEIR DREAMS REALIZED. THEY
MOVED THROUGH SEALS THE SEAL
TRAINING THEY BECAME NAVY SEALS.
THEY SERVED IN HOT SPOTS AROUND
THE WORLD. I KNEW BECAUSE I GOT
REPORTS FROM MY VERY VERY GOOD
FRIEND WHO COULDN'T TELL ME
WHERE THEY WERE BECAUSE SHE
DIDN'T KNOW. EXCEPT THAT SHE
KNEW THEY WERE OVER THERE
SOMEWHERE. DOING GOOD THINGS.
THEY RECEIVED NUMEROUS MILITARY
DECORATIONS. AND THEY WERE IN
DANGER EVERY SINGLE DAY THEY
WERE DEPLOYED. AND NATE AND
CHRIS. ALWAYS CAME BACK UNTIL
THAT DAY ON JANUARY, 11 OFF THE
COAST OF SOMALIA. WHEN CHRIS DID
NOT. TODAY SHOULD BE A REMINDER
TO ALL OF US. REMINDER THAT WE
HAVE SONS AND DAUGHTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. PROTECTING US, NOT
ONLY IN OUR CITIES AND IN OUR
COUNTIES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND ON OUR STREETS BUT ALSO
SERVING IN OUR ARMED FORCES.
AROUND THE WORLD EVERY DAY. SONS
AND DAUGHTERS OF CALIFORNIA JUST
LIKE CHRIS. AND LIKE CHRIS. SOME
NEVER NEVER COME HOME. I HAVE TO
SAY THAT I WAS MORE THAN A BIT
DISAPPOINTED AS I DROVE INTO THE
CAPITAL AND TO WORK TODAY. TO
SEE THAT OUR NATION'S FLAG ATOP
THE CAPITOL WAS IT FULL STAFF.
AND I WONDERED WHY. OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THOSE WHO SERVE TO
PROTECT AND DEFEND US. WHEREVER
THEY'RE DOING SO AND WHO GIVE
ALL THEY HAVE TO GIVE AN
OCCASIONALLY. THEN SOME THEY
DESERVE MORE. CHRIS CERTAINLY
DOES. SO I JOINED MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. IN ASKING
THAT WE KEEP CHRIS FAMILY AND
NATE. IN OUR PRAYERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES AND THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE. PLEASE
BRING THE NAME FORD SO HE COULD
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR TATO.
GOOD MORNING, MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. I STAND
BEFORE YOU TODAY ON FEBRUARY 1ST
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHERE RED DAY AT
THE CAPITOL AND THE COMMENCEMENT
OF AMERICAN HEART MONTH EXTEND
MY GRATITUDE TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CAUSE AND LOVE
SEEING ALL THE RED
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN WOMEN
CLAIMING MORE LIVES THAN ALL
CANCERS COMBINED. BY WHERE RED,
WE ARE HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED TO
RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND HELP
SAVE LIVES. NEXT WEEK, WE WILL
BE TAKING UP THE SENATE
RESOLUTION, AND IN ADDITION, MY
OFFICE AND THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION WILL BE HOSTING A
BLOOD PRESSURE, SCREENING AND
HANDS. AH ONLY CPR TRAINING AND
ROOM 80 2080 10 FROM 10 AM TO
ONE PM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS BEFORE WE ADJOURNED
TODAY, WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SENATOR TONY ATKINS FOR HER
TIRELESS SERVICE ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE GOLDEN STATE.
AS THE 48TH PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THERE WILL BE A FORMAL
RECOGNITION OF THE PRO TUNE BY
THIS BODY SOON. BUT TODAY WE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER IN THE PRO TEM THAT HAVE
A FEW WORDS SENATOR JONES UNDER
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I DO HAVE
NOTES FOR THIS. I'M GOING TO TRY
TO STICK TO THEM. OTHERWISE THEY
PROBABLY WON'T GET THROUGH THIS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IN
IN FIRST RECOGNITION OF PRO TIM
ATKINS AS I WAS CONTEMPLATING
WHAT TO SHARE THIS MORNING. I
KNOW IT'S IN THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY AND A LONG TIME THAT THE
SAME MEMBER HAS SERVED AS
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY AND PRO
TIM OF THE SIN, I THINK IN OVER
100 YEARS AND I HAVEN'T
RESEARCHED MY HISTORY COMPLETE.
BUT IT MIGHT ALSO BE THE FIRST
TIME IN HISTORY THAT A PRO TIM
OUTLASTED FOR MINORITY LEADERS.
REPUBLICAN LEADERS. I'M NOT SURE
IF THAT'S THE CASE OR NOT, BUT
AND IN SPEAKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE SERVED AS
LEADER, BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
HERE IN THE SENATE, UH, ONE OF
THE MOST COMMON THEMES THAT I
HEAR FROM ALL OF MY MEMBERS. IS
THAT PRO TEAM ATKINS IS FAIR.
WELL, FIRST I HEAR SHE'S TOUGH.
WHICH I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
BUT FAIR. AND, UM. AND I THINK
THOSE ARE GOOD. PRINCIPLES THAT
GO WELL TOGETHER. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES TO BE A LEADER. IN A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA. TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO YOU, BUT ALSO GIVE
RESPECT TO THE OPINIONS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT THAN YOURS. YOU HAVE
TO BE TOUGH AND FAIR. AND SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW OR MAY NOT
KNOW THAT I HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH PRO TIM
ATKINS FOR ALMOST 20 YEARS. WHEN
I WAS ELECTED TO THE SANTEE CITY
COUNCIL, AND SHE WAS ELECTED TO
THE SAN DIEGO CITY COUNCIL. WE
BOTH SHOWED UP TO MTS. I THINK
SHE GOT THERE A COUPLE OF MONTHS
BEFORE I DID, WHICH IS THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSMITS IS
TRANSIT SYSTEM. AND UM SOME OF
THE FOLKS HAVE BEEN ON THAT
BOARD FOR A LONG, LONG TIME. AND
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE, HONOR AND
GOOD FORTUNE OF BEING SEATED
NEXT TO PRO TIM ATKINS BECAUSE I
DID NOT KNOW A THING ABOUT MTS
OR TRANSPORTATION OR BUSSES OR
TAXIS OR TROLLEYS OR ANY OF THAT
STUFF. AND, UH, SHE TOOK ME
UNDER HER WING A LITTLE BIT.
THERE WAS AGAIN EVEN BACK THEN
SOME THINGS THAT WE DISAGREED
ON. BUT WE AGREED TO WORK
TOGETHER AND ALWAYS KEEP THE
CONVERSATION PROFESSIONAL. AND
UM, AND KEEPING THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR SHARED
CONSTITUENTS IN MIND. AS ONE OF
HER IDOLS. THE GREAT DOLLY
PARTON HAS SAID YOU WILL NEVER
DO A WHOLE LOT. UNLESS YOU'RE
BRAVE ENOUGH TO TRY MS. ATKINS
HAS BEEN BRAVE ENOUGH TO TRY AND
SHE HAS SUCCEEDED. AND I BELIEVE
AS A STUDENT OF LEADERSHIP
MYSELF THAT SHE TRULY EMBODIES
THE PRINCIPLE OF A SERVANT
LEADER. AND I BELIEVE THAT SHE
WILL BE MISSED AS OUR CAPTAIN
HERE ON THE SENATE FLOOR. THE
NEXT GUY HAS SOME BIG SHOES TO
FILL. AND I'VE NOTICED A
PROTEIN. I HOPE THIS IS OKAY TO
SAY SHE'S WEARING COWBOY BOOTS
TODAY. SO, UH, YOU KNOW THE
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY, UM, A MESSAGE
TO THOSE THAT WANT TO FOLLOW
HER. IN THIS, UH ADVENTURE. AND
I WANT TO, YOU KNOW, I'M I'M
HERE STANDING, OBVIOUSLY, AND
REPRESENTATION OF THE ENTIRE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS TO SAY THANK
YOU. UH BUT PERSONALLY, I HAVE
TO SAY THANK YOU AS WELL. UH AND
JUST GOING BACK TO THAT
PROFESSIONALISM WE HAVE HAD VERY
STRONG POLICY DEBATES AND
DISAGREEMENTS. BUT I THINK BOTH
OF US HAVE ALWAYS TRIED TO KEEP
THAT AT THE PROFESSIONAL LEVEL.
AND I KIND OF, UM COMPARE IT TO
RONALD REAGAN AND TIP O NEILL.
YOU KNOW THEY COULD HAVE
VIGOROUS DEBATE. AND THEN AT THE
END OF THE EVENING, GO SHARE A
DRINK TOGETHER OR A MEAL
TOGETHER, AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT AS WELL. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE DONE THAT. WITH ALL OF
THE ALL OF OUR MEMBERS, AND I
THANK YOU FOR THAT, AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS DAY
IS NOT LEFT WITHOUT ALL OF US IN
THE MINORITY CAUCUS, SAYING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE DONE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES, AND
I'LL JUST STAND CORRECTED. THOSE
ARE FAR FROM COWBOY BOOTS. I'LL
BE CLEAR ON THAT. PRO TELLME
ATKINS. WELL MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU. AND UM, YOU KNOW, WE PAID
RESPECTS, UH, AND ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF THREE INCREDIBLE
SERVANTS TODAY, AND SO YOU
ALMOST LOST ME ON THE LAST ONE.
SO THAT WAS NOT A GOOD WAY TO
START MY COMMENTS. UM BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. I STAND
HERE AFTER HEARING THOSE
COMMENTS OF LEADERS WE HAVE
LOST. AND HERE AND FROM MY
FRIEND FROM SANTEE, UM, THE
SENATE. UH REPUBLICAN LEADER. I
NEVER LIKE TO SAY MINORITY
LEADER UM I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT. UM THERE WILL BE A
TIME LATER THIS YEAR FOR ALL OF
US WHO ARE ACTUALLY LEAVING THE
SENATE TO SAY GOODBYE AND
REFLECT ON OUR TIME IN THIS
INCREDIBLE INSTITUTION, SO TODAY
WILL NOT BE THAT DAY, BUT GIVEN
THAT THERE WILL BE A WONDERFUL
TRANSITION ON MONDAY. I WANTED
TO TAKE JUST A MINUTE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU. THANK
YOU FOR INTERESTING ME WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THIS BODY.
YOU'RE NEVER ABLE TO LEAD UNLESS
SOMEONE ALLOWS YOU TO LEAD. I
WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE WHO ASPIRE
TO BE LEADERS THAT THAT REALLY
IS THE POINT. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO BRING CREDIT
TO OUR SENATE. SERVING AND
CREATING OPPORTUNITY, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
SINCE THIS IS THE LAST SESSION,
I WILL ADJOURN HIS PRO TEAM. I
CAN'T LEAVE WITHOUT THANKING OUR
STAFFS AND PARTICULARLY MY STAFF
, AND I FULLY INTENDED TO TURN
AROUND AND LOOK AT THEM. BUT I
AM NOT ABLE TO DO THAT, BECAUSE
THEN I WILL NOT GET THROUGH THE
OTHER HALF PAGE I HAVE HERE. SO
JUST KNOW THAT I LOVE YOU ALL. I
ALWAYS SAY THAT MY DISTRICT
STAFF LED BY PAM ISON. THEY HAVE
THEIR FINGER ON THE PULSE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT IN
SAN DIEGO. THAT'S REALLY TRUE.
THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND THE HEARTS
AND THE DREAMS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO HELP THEM. I WOULD
ASK ALL OF YOU I KNOW IT'S UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. BUT PLEASE
KEEP SAYING DIEGO IN YOUR
PRAYERS THIS WEEK AS WE FACE
MORE RAIN. AFTER THE DEVASTATION
OF TWO WEEKS AGO, AND I WANT TO
EXTEND MY THANKS TO O. E S AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THEIR
HELP WITH THAT. TO THE STAFF WHO
ARE COMING WITH ME TO THE
EMERITUS OFFICE, INCLUDING THE
INCREDIBLE CHIEF OF STAFF, NICK
HARTMAN. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO EACH OF THEM NOW.
THEORETICALLY IT SHOULD BE LESS
CRAZY, BUT I'M NOT MAKING ANY
PROMISES. I JUST NOTICED, UH,
THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF, THE CHIEF
OF STAFF, ALLEGED SECRETARY AND
DEPUTY LEDGE SECRETARY HAVE
JOINED US TO SAY OR TO HONOR ME
AND I WANT TO SAY WHAT AN HONOR
THAT IS TO THEM. THANK YOU FOR
WHAT AN HONOR. IT IS FOR ME FOR
THEM TO BE HERE. FORGIVE ME. UM,
I'M REALLY TOUCHED. I WANT TO
SAY TO OUR NEXT PRO TIM, YOU
WERE INHERITING AN INCREDIBLE
STAFF, AND THEY'RE BACK HERE
BEHIND ME TODAY AGAIN, I CANNOT
LOOK AT THEM. UH, BUT I WANT TO
SAY UM, SENATOR MCGUIRE. THEY
ARE SMART. THEY ARE CAPABLE.
THEY'RE KIND AND WE'LL HELP YOU
DO GREAT WORK POLICY.
COMMUNICATIONS RULES THE DEATH
STAFF TRUST ME, THEY WILL
CONSISTENTLY IMPRESS AND AMAZE
YOU. SECRETARY CONTRERAS AND
YOUR TEAM. AND TO OUR CHIEF
SERGEANT RODRIGUEZ AND HER
INCREDIBLE TEAM. THERE ARE NO
WORDS TO EXPRESS MY RESPECT AND
MY ADMIRATION FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE TO MAKE THE SENATE
WORK AND TO MAKE US SAFE. THANK
YOU. AND THERE ISN'T A DAY THAT
GOES BY THAT WE DON'T OWE A DEBT
OF GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE AT DGS.
WHO WORKED SO HARD TO TAKE SUCH
GOOD CARE OF THE CAPITAL, THE L.
O B AND A SWING SPACE THREE
BUILDINGS. AND FINALLY, MR PRO
TIM DESIGNEE, UM IN THE DARKEST
OF TIMES, I WOULD SUGGEST YOU
JUST DO WHAT I DO. IT'S ALWAYS
WORKED WELL FOR ME. JUST LEAN
OUT THE DOOR AND YELL BERNIE.
AND EVERYTHING WILL BE OK. SO
EVERYBODY, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE HONOR. IT'S BEEN, IT'S BEEN
AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE. THIS
BODY.
PUT ON YOUR SUNDAY BEST FOR
MONDAY BECAUSE OUR NEXT SESSION
AND IT WILL BE A GOOD ONE IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY. FEBRUARY
5TH 2024 AT 1:30 P.M. MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 330 AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLEDGED. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT 130.